(humming)
- [Narrator] In train and
subway stations all over Japan,
you're likely to hear a fully composed
seven-second jingle that is uniquely
written for that station.
And if you're one of the millions
of Tokyo metro riders
You've probably heard one of these jingles
composed by Minoru Mukaiya.
(lively music)
(soft music)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Over time,
Mr. Mukaiya shifted
his focus to his other passion-trains-
and formed a company
that builds simulators.
In this world of trains,
he found a new outlet for his music
and got to work composing train melodies.
Like this one
(Shibuya Station music)
(pensive music)
(Ochiai music)
(Takadanobaba music)
(Monzen-Nakachō music)
(Waseda music)
- [Narrator] Having found a
marriage of his two passions,
today, Mr. Mukaiya considers
himself a lucky man.